The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I want to review zero-mean
jointly
Gaussian random variables.
And I want to review a
couple of the other
things I did last time.
Because when I get into
questions of stationarity and
things like that today, I think
it will be helpful to
have a little better sense of
what all that was about, or it
will just look like
a big mess.
And there are sort of a small
number of critical things
there that we have
to understand.
One of them is that if you have
a non-singular covariance
matrix, OK, you have a bunch
of random variables.
This bunch of random variables,
each one of them
has a has a covariance.
Namely, z sub i and z sub j have
an expected value of z
sub i and z sub j.
I'm just talking about
zero mean here.
Anytime I don't say whether
there's a mean or not, I mean
there isn't a mean.
But I think the notes are
usually pretty careful.
If the covariance matrix is
non-singular, then the
following things happen.
The vector, z, is jointly
Gaussian.
And our first definition
was, if you can
represent it as a --
all the components of it each as
linear combinations of IID
normal Gaussian random
variables, namely independent
Gaussian random variables -- so
they're all just built up
from this common set
of independent
Gaussian random variables.
Which sort of matches
our idea of why
noise should be Gaussian.
Namely, it comes from a
collection of a whole bunch of
independent things, which all
get added up in various ways.
And we're trying to look at
processes, noise processes.
The thing that's going to happen
then is that, at each
epoch in time, the noise is
going to be some linear
combination of all of these
noise effects, but is going to
be filtered a little bit.
And because it's being filtered
a little bit, the
noise at one time and the noise
at another time are all
going to depend on common
sets of variables.
So that's the intuitive
idea here.
Starting with that idea, last
time we derived what the
probability density had to be.
And if you remember, this
probability density came out
rather simply.
The only thing that was involved
here was this idea of
going from little cubes in
the IID noise domain into
parallelograms in
the z domain.
Which is what happens when
you go through a linear
transformation.
And because of that, this is the
density that has to come
out of there.
By knowing a little bit
about matrices --
which is covered in the
appendix, or you can just take
it on faith if you want to --
you can break up this matrix
into eigenvalues and
eigenvectors.
If the matrix is
nonsingular --
well, if the matrix is singular
or nonsingular, if
it's a covariance matrix,
or it's --
a non-negative definite matrix,
is what these matrices
are -- then you can always
break this matrix up into
eigenvalues and eigenvectors.
The eigenvectors
span the space.
The eigenvectors can
be taken to be
orthonormal to each other.
And then when you express this
in those terms, this
probability density becomes
just a product of normal
Gaussian random variable
densities, where the
particular Gaussian random
variables are these inner
products of the noise vector
with these various
eigenvectors.
In other words, you're taking
this set of random variables
which you're expressing in some
reference system, where
z1 up to z sub k are
the different
components to the vector.
When you express this in a
different reference system,
you're rotating that
space around.
What this says is, you can
always rotate the space in
such a way that what you will
find is orthogonal random
variables, which are independent
of each other.
So that this is the density
that you wind up having.
And what this means is, if you
look at the region of equal
probability density over this
set of random variables, what
you find is it's a bunch
of ellipsoids.
And the axes of the ellipsoids
are simply these
eigenvectors here.
OK, so this is the third way.
If you can represent the noise
in this way, again, it has to
be jointly Gaussian.
Finally, if all linear
combinations of this random
vector are Gaussian, that's
probably the simplest one.
But it's the hardest one
to verify, in a sense.
And it's the hardest one
to get all these
other results from.
But if all linear combinations
of these random variables are
all Gaussian, then in fact,
again, the variables have to
be jointly Gaussian.
Again, it's important to
understand that jointly
Gaussian means more than just
individually Gaussian.
It doesn't mean what you would
think from the words jointly
Gaussian, as saying that each of
the variables are Gaussian.
It means a whole lot
more than that.
In the problem set, what you've
done in one of the
problems is to create a couple
of examples of two random
variables which are each
Gaussian random variables, but
which jointly are not
jointly Gaussian.
OK, finally, if you have a
singular covariance matrix, z
is jointly Gaussian if
a basis of these
zi's are jointly Gaussian.
OK?
In other words, you throw out
the random variables which are
just linear combinations of the
others, because you don't
even want to think of those as
random variables in a sense.
I mean, technically they are
random variables, because
they're defined in
the sample space.
But they're all just defined in
terms of other things, so
who cares about them?
So after you throw those
out, the others have
to be jointly Gaussian.
So in fact, if you have two
random variables, z1 and z2,
and z2 equals z1 --
OK, in other words the
probability density is on a
straight diagonal line --
and z1 is Gaussian, z1
and z2 are jointly
Gaussian in that case.
This is not an example like
the ones you did in this
problem set that you're handing
in today, where you in
fact have things like a
probability density which
doesn't exist because it's
impulsive on this line, and
also impulsive on this line.
Or something which looks
Gaussian in two of the
quadrants and is zero in both
the other quadrants, and
really bizarre things
like that.
OK?
So please try to understand what
jointly Gaussian means.
Because everything about noise
that we do is based on that.
It really is.
And if you don't know what
jointly Gaussian means, you're
not going to understand
anything about noise
detection, or anything
from this point on.
I know last year I kept telling
people that, and in
the final exam there were still
four or five people who
didn't have the foggiest idea
what jointly Gaussian meant.
And you know, you're not going
to understand the rest of
this, you're not going to
understand why these things
are happening, if you don't
understand that.
OK.
So the next thing we
said is Z of t --
I use those little curly
brackets around something just
as a shorthand way of saying
that what I'm interested in
now is the random process, not
the random variable at a
particular value of t.
In other words, if I say Z of
t, what I'm usually talking
about is a random variable,
which is the random variable
corresponding to one particular
epoch of this
random process.
Here I'm talking about
the whole process.
And it's a Gaussian process.
If Z of t1 to Z of tk are
jointly Gaussian for all k and
for all sets of t sub i.
And if the process can be
represented as a linear
combination of just ordinary
random variables multiplied by
some set of orthonormal
functions, and these Z sub i
are independent, and if the sum
of the variances of these
random variables sum up to
something less than infinity.
So you have finite energy in
these sample functions,
effectively is what this says.
Then it says the sample
functions of Z of t are L2
with probability one.
OK.
You have almost proven that
in the problem set.
If you don't believe that you've
almost proven it, you
really have.
And anyway, it's true.
One of the things that we're
trying to do when we're trying
to deal with these wave forms
that we transmit, the only way
we can deal with them very
carefully is to know that
they're L2 functions.
Which means they have
Fourier transforms.
We can do all this stuff
we've been doing.
And you don't need anything more
mathematically than that.
So it's important to be dealing
with L2 functions.
We're now getting into random
processes, and it's important
to know that the sample
functions are L2.
Because so long as the sample
functions are L2, then you can
do all of these things we've
done before and just put it
together and say well,
you take a big
ensemble of these things.
They're all well defined,
they're all L2.
We can take Fourier transforms,
we can do
everything else we want to do.
OK, so that's the game
we're playing.
OK, I'm just going to assume
that sample functions are L2
from now on, except in a couple
of bizarre cases that
we look at.
Then a linear functional is a
random variable given by the
random variable is equal to
the integral of the noise
process z of t, multiplied
by an ordinary
function, g of t, dt.
And we talked about that
a lot last time.
This is the convolution of a
process -- well, it's not the
convolution.
It's just the inner product of
a process with a function.
And we interpret this last time
in terms of the sample
functions of the process and
the sample values of the
random variable.
And then since we could do that,
we could really talk
about the random
variable here.
This means that for all of the
sample values in the sample
space with probability one,
the sample values of the
random variable v are equal to
the integral of the sample
values of the process
times g of t dt.
OK, in other words,
this isn't really
something unusual and new.
I mean, students have the
capacity of looking at this in
two ways, and I've seen
it happen for years.
The first time you see this,
you say this is trivial.
Because it just looks like the
kind of integration you're
doing all your life.
You work with it for a while,
and then at some point you
wake up and you say, oh,
but my god, this is
not a function here.
This is a random process.
And you say, what the
heck does this mean?
And suddenly you're way
out in left field.
Well, this says what it means.
Once you know what it means, we
go back to this and we use
this from now on.
OK?
If we have a zero-mean Gaussian
process z of t, if
you have L2 sample functions,
like you had when you take a
process and make it up as a
linear combination of random
variables times orthonormal
functions, and if you have a
bunch of different L2 functions,
g1 up to g sub j 0,
then each of these random
variables, each of these
linear functionals, are
going to be Gaussian.
And in fact the whole
set of them
together are jointly Gaussian.
And we showed that last time.
I'm not going to bother
to show it again.
And we also found what the
covariance was between these
random variables.
And it was just this
expression here.
OK.
And this follows just by taking
vi, which is this kind
of integral, times vj, and
interchanging the order of
integration, taking the expected
value of z of t times
z of tau, which gives
you this quantity.
And you have the g i of t and
the g j of t stuck in there
with an integral around it.
And it's hard to understand what
those integrals mean and
whether they really exist or
not, but we'll get to that a
little later.
We then talked about linear
filtering of processes.
You have a process coming into
a filter, and the output is
some other stochastic process.
Or at least we hope it's a well
defined stochastic process.
And we talked a little bit
about this last time.
And for every value of tau,
namely for each random
variable in this output random
process, V of tau is just a
linear functional.
It's a linear functional
corresponding to the
particular function h
of that tau minus t.
So the linear functional is a
function of t here for the
particular value of tau that
you have over here.
So this is just a linear
functional like the ones we've
been talking about.
OK, if z of t is a zero-mean
Gaussian process, then you
have a bunch of different linear
functionals here for
any set of times tau
1 up to tau sub k.
And those are jointly Gaussian
from what we just said.
And if all of these sets
of k sample --
If based a random process, v of
tau, is a Gaussian random
process, if for all k sets of
epochs, v, tau 1, tau 2, up to
tau sub k, if this set of
random variables are all
jointly Gaussian.
So that's what we have here.
So the V of tau is actually a
Gaussian process if Z of t is
a Gaussian random process
to start with.
And the covariance function is
just this quantity that we
talked about before.
OK, so we have a covariance
function.
We also have a covariance
function for the process we
started with.
And if it's Gaussian, all you
need to know is what the
covariance function is.
So that's all rather nice.
OK, as we said, we're going
to start talking about
stationarity today.
I really want to talk about
two ideas of stationarity.
One is the idea that you
have probably seen as
undergraduates one place or
another, which is simple
computationally, but is almost
impossible to understand when
you try to say something
precise about it.
And the other is something
called effectively stationary,
which we're going to
talk about today.
And I'll show you why
that makes sense.
So we say that a process Z of
t is stationary if, for all
integers k, all shifts tau, all
epochs t1 to t sub k, and
all of values of z1 to zk, this
joint density here is
equal to the joint
density shifted.
In other words, what we're doing
is we're taking a set of
times over here, t1,
t2, t3, t4, t5.
We're looking at the joint
distribution function for
those random variables
here, and then we're
shifting it by tau.
And we're saying if the process
is stationery, the
joint distribution function here
has to be the same as the
joint distribution
function there.
You might think that all you
need is the distribution
function here has to be the
same as the distribution
function there.
But you really want the same
relationship to hold through
here as there if you want to
call process stationary.
OK.
If we have zero-mean Gauss,
that's just equivalent to
saying that the covariance
function at ti and t sub j is
the same as the covariance
function at ti plus
tau and tj plus tau.
And that's true for
t1 up to t sub k.
Which really just means this
has to be true for all tau,
for all t sub i and
for all t sub j.
So you don't need to worry about
the k at all once you're
dealing with a Gaussian
process.
Because all you need
to worry about is
the covariance function.
And the covariance function
is only a function of two
variables, the process at one
epoch and the process at
another epoch.
And this is equivalent, even
more simply, to saying that
the covariance function at t1
and t2 has to be equal to the
covariance function at
t1 minus t2 and zero.
Can you see why that is?
If I start out with this, and I
know that this is true, then
the thing that I can do is take
this and I can shift it
by any amount that I want to.
So if I shift this by adding tau
here, then what I wind up
with is kz of t1 minus t2 plus
tau, comma tau, is equal to kz
of t1 plus tau, t2 plus tau.
And if I change variables
around a little
bit, I come to this.
So this is the condition we need
for a Gaussian process to
be stationary.
I would defy any of you to ever
show in any way that a
process satisfies all
of these conditions.
I mean, if you don't have nice
structural properties in the
process, like a Gaussian
process, which says that all
you need to define it is this,
this is something that you
just can't deal with
very well.
So we have this.
And then we say, OK, this
covariance is so easy
to work with --
I mean no, it's not easy to work
with, but it's one hell
of a lot easier to work
with than that.
And therefore if you want to
start talking about processes,
and you don't really want to
go into all the detail of
these joint distribution
functions, you will say to
yourselves that one thing I
might ask for in a process is
the question of whether the
covariance function satisfies
this property.
I mean, for a Gaussian process
this is all you need to make
the process stationary.
For other processes you need
more, but at least it's an
interesting question to ask.
Is the process partly
stationary, in the sense that
the covariance function at
least is stationary?
Namely, the covariance function
here looks the same
as the covariance
function there.
So we say that a zero-mean
process is wide-sense
stationary if it satisfies
this condition.
So a Gaussian process then is
stationary if and only if it's
wide-sense stationary.
And a random process with a
mean, or with a mean that
isn't necessarily zero, is
going to be stationary or
wide-sense stationary if the
mean is constant and the
fluctuation is stationary.
Or wide-sense stationary,
as the case may be.
So you want both of these
properties there.
So as before, we're just going
to throw out the mean and not
worry about it.
Because if we're thinking of it
as noise, it's not going to
have a mean.
Because of it has a mean, it's
not part of the noise.
It's just something we
know, and we might
as well remove it.
OK, interesting example here.
Let's look at a process,
V of t, which is
defined in this way here.
It's the sum of a set of random
variables, V sub k,
times the sinc function for
some sampling interval,
capital T. And I'm assuming
that the v sub k are
zero-mean, and that, at least
as far as second moments are
concerned, they have
this stationarity
property between them.
Namely, they are uncorrelated
from one j to another k.
Expected value of vj squared
is sigma squared.
Expected value of vj vk for
k unequal to j is zero.
So they're uncorrelated; they
all have the same variance.
Then I claim that the process
V of t is wide-sense
stationary.
And I claim that this covariance
function is going
to be sigma squared times sinc
of t minus tau over t.
Now for how many of you
is this an obvious
consequence of that?
How many of you would
guess this if you
had to guess something?
Well, if you wouldn't guess
it, you should.
Any time you don't know
something, the best thing to
do is to make a guess and try
to see whether your guess is
right or not.
Because otherwise you never
know what to do.
So if you have a function
which is
defined in this way --
think of it this way.
Suppose these V sub k's were
not random variables, but
instead suppose they were
all just constants.
Suppose they were all 1.
Suppose you're looking at the
function V of t, which is the
sum of all of the
sinc functions.
And think of what you'd get
when you add up a bunch of
sinc functions which are
all exactly the same.
What do you get?
I mean, you have to get
a constant, right?
You're just interpolating
between all these points, and
all the points are the same.
So it'd be very bizarre
if you didn't get
something which was constant.
Well the same thing
happens here.
The derivation of this is one of
those derivations which is
very, very simple and very, very
slick and very elegant.
And I was going to go through it
in class and I thought, no.
You just can't follow
this in real time.
It's something you have
to sit down and think
about for five minutes.
So I urge you all to read this,
because this is a trick
that you need to use
all the time.
And you should understand it,
because various problems as we
go along are going to use this
idea in various ways.
But anyway, when you have a
process defined this way, it
has to be wide-sense
stationary.
And the covariance function is
just this function here.
Now if these V sub k up here are
jointly Gaussian, and they
all have the same variance, so
they're all IID, then what
this means is you have a
Gaussian random process.
And it's a stationary Gaussian
random process.
In other words, it's a process
where, if you look at the
random variable v of tau at
any given tau, you get the
same thing for all tau.
In other words, it's a little
peculiar, in the sense that
when you look at this,
it looks like time 0
was a little special.
Because time 0 is where you
specified the process.
Time t you specified
the process.
Time 2t you specified
But in fact this
is saying, no.
Time 0 is not special at all.
Which is why we say that the
process is wide-sense
stationary.
All times look the same.
On the other hand, if you take
these V sub k here to be
binary random variables which
take one the value plus 1 or
minus 1 with equal probability,
what do you have then?
You look at the sum here, and at
the sample points -- namely
at 0, at t, at 2t, and so forth
-- what values can the
process take away?
At time 0?
If v sub 0 is either plus
1 or minus 1, what
is v of 0 over here?
It's plus 1 or minus 1.
It can only be those
two things.
If you look at V of capital T
over 2, namely if you look
halfway between these two sample
points, you then ask,
what are the different
values that v of T
over 2 can take on?
It's an awful mess.
It's a very bizarre
random variable.
But anyway, it's not a random
variable which is
plus or minus 1.
Because it's really a sum of an
infinite number of terms.
So you're taking an infinite
number of binary random
variables, each with arbitrary
multipliers.
So you're adding them all up.
So you get something that's
not differentiable.
It's not anything nice.
I don't care about that.
The only thing that I care about
is that v of capital T
over 2 is not a binary random
variable anymore.
And therefore this process is
not stationary anymore.
Here's an example of a
wide-sense stationary process
which is not stationary.
So it's a nice example of where
you have wide-sense
stationarity, but you don't
have stationarity.
So all kinds of questions about
power and things like
that, this process works
very, very well.
Because questions about power
you answer only in terms of
covariance functions.
Questions of individual
possible values and
probability distributions you
can't answer the very well.
One more thing.
If these variables are Gaussian,
and if you actually
believe me that this is a
stationary Gaussian process,
and it really is a stationary
Gaussian process, what we have
is a way of creating a broad
category of random processes.
Because if I look at the sample
functions here of this
process, each sample function
is bandlimited.
Baseband limited.
And it's baseband limited to 1
over 2 times capital T. 1 over
the quantity 2 times capital T.
So by choosing capital T to
be different things, I can make
these sample functions
have large bandwidth or small
bandwidth so I can look at a
large variety of different
things.
All of them have Fourier
transforms, which look sort of
flat in magnitude.
And we'll talk about
that as we go on.
And when I pass these things
through linear filters, what
we're going to find is we can
create any old Gaussian random
process we want to.
So that's why they're nice.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Can we make
V of t white noise?
In a practical sense, yes.
In a mathematical sense, no.
In a mathematical sense,
you can't make
anything white noise.
In a mathematical sense, white
noise is something
which does not exist.
I'm going to get to
that later today.
And it's a good question.
But the answer is yes and no.
OK, the trouble with stationary
processes is that
the sample functions
aren't L2.
That's not the serious problem
with them, because all of us
as engineers are willing to say,
well, whether it's L2 or
not I don't care.
I'm just going to use it because
it looks like a nice
random process.
It's not going to burn anything
else or anything.
So, so what?
But the serious problem here is
that it's very difficult to
view stationary processes as
approximations to real processes.
I mean, we've already said that
you can't have a random
process which is running
merrily away
before the Big Bang.
And you can't have something
that's going to keep on
running along merrily after we
destroy ourselves, which is
probably sooner in the
future than the Big
Bang was in the past.
But anyway, this definition of
stationarity does not give us
any way to approximate this.
Namely, if a process is
stationary, it is either
identically zero, or every
sample function with
probability one has infinite
energy in it.
In other words, they keep
running on forever.
They keep building up
energy as they go.
And as far as the definitions
current is concerned, there's
no way to say large negative
times and large positive times
are unimportant.
If you're going to use
mathematical things, though
you're using them as
approximations, you really
have to consider what they're
approximations to.
So that's why I'm going to
develop this idea of
effectively wide-sense
stationary or effectively
stationary.
OK.
So a zero-mean process is
effectively stationary or
effectively wide-sense
stationary, which is what I'm
primarily interested in, within
two intervals, within
some wide interval of time,
minus T0 to plus T0.
I'm thinking here of choosing
T0 to be enormous.
Namely if you build a piece of
equipment, you would have
minus T0 to plus T0 include the
amount of time that the
equipment was running.
So we'll say it's effectively
stationary within these limits
if the joint probability
assignment, or the covariance
matrix if we're talking about
effectively wide-sense
stationary, for t1 up to t sub
k is the same as that for t1
plus tau up to tk plus tau.
In other words I have this big
interval, and I have a bunch
of times here.
t sub k.
And I have a bunch of times over
here, t1 plus tau up to
tk plus tau.
And this set of times don't have
to be disjoint from that
set of times.
And I have this time over here,
minus t0, and I have
this time way out here
which is plus t0.
And what I'm saying is, I'm
going to call this function
wide-sense stationery if, when
we truncate it to minus t0 to
plus t0, it is stationary
as far as all
those times are concerned.
In other words, we just want to
ignore what happens before
minus t0 and what happens
after plus t0.
You have to be able
to do that.
Because if you can't talk about
the process in that way,
you can't talk about
the process at all.
The only thing you can do is
view the noise over some
finite interval.
OK.
And as far as covariance matrix
for wide-sense and
stationary, well it's
the same definition.
So we're going to truncate the
process and deal with that.
For effectively stationary
or effectively wide-sense
stationary, I want to view the
process as being truncated to
minus t0 to plus t0.
We have this process which
might or might not be
stationary.
I just truncate it and I say I'm
only going to look at this
finite segment of it.
I'm going to define this one
variable covariance function
as kz of t1 and t2.
And kz of t1 and t2 is
going to be -- blah.
The single variable covariance
function is defined as kz if
t1 minus t2 is equal to the
actual covariance function
evaluated with one argument
at t1 and the
other argument at t2.
And I want this to hold
true for all t1 and
all t2 in this interval.
And this square here gives
a picture of what
we're talking about.
If you look at the square in the
notes, unfortunately all
the diagonal lines do not appear
because of the bizarre
characteristics of LaTeX.
LaTeX is better than most
programs, but the graphics in
it are awful.
But anyway, here it
is drawn properly.
And along this line, t minus
tau is constant.
So this is the line over which
we're insisting that kz of t1
and t2 be constant.
So for a random process to be
wide-sense stationary, what
were insisting is that within
these limits, minus t0 to plus
t0, the covariance function is
constant along each of these
lines along here.
So it doesn't depend
on both t1 and t2.
It only depends on the
difference between them.
Which is what we require for
stationary to start with.
If you don't like the idea
of effectively wide-sense
stationary, just truncate the
process and say, well if it's
stationary, this has
to be satisfied.
It has to be constant
along these lines.
The peculiar thing about this
is that the single variable
covariance function does not run
from minus t0 to plus t0.
It runs from minus
2T0 to plus 2T0.
So that's a little bizarre
and a little unpleasant.
And it's unfortunately
the way things are.
And it also says that this one
variable covariance function
is not always the same as the
covariance evaluated at t
minus tau and 0.
Namely, it's not the same
because t minus tau might be
considerably larger than t0.
And therefore, this covariance
is zero, if we truncated the
process, and this covariance
is not zero.
In other words, for these points
up here, and in fact
this point in particular --
well, I guess the best thing
to look at is points along
here, for example.
Points along here, what we
insist on is that t minus tau,
k sub z of t and tau is constant
along this line.
But we don't insist on kz of
t minus tau, which is some
quantity bigger than t0 along
this line, being the same as
this quantity here.
OK, so aside from that little
peculiarity, this is the same
thing that you would expect from
just taking a function
and truncating it.
There's nothing else that's
peculiar going on there.
OK, so let's see if we can do
anything with this idea.
And the first thing we want to
do is to say, how about these
linear functionals we've
been talking about?
Why do I keep talking
about linear
functionals and filtering?
Because any time you take a
noise process and you receive
it, you're going to start
filtering it.
You're going to take
start taking linear
functionals of it.
Namely all the processing you
do is going to start with
finding random variables
in this particular way.
And when you look at the
covariance between two of
them, what you find is the same
thing we found last time.
Expected value of Vi times Vj is
equal to the integral of gi
of t times the covariance
function evaluated at t and
tau, times gj of tau.
All of this is for
real processes
and for real functions.
Because noise random processes
are in fact real.
I keep trying to alternate
between making all of this
complex and making it real.
Both have their advantages.
But at least in the present
version of the notes,
everything is real, concerned
with random processes.
So I have this function here.
If gj of t is zero for t greater
than T0, what's going
to happen here then?
I'm evaluating this where
this is a double
integral over what region?
It's a double integral over
the region where t is
constrained to minus T0
to plus T0, and tau is
constrained to the interval
minus t0 to plus T0.
In other words, I can evaluate
this expected value, this
covariance, simply by looking
at this box here.
If I know what the random
process is doing within this
box, I can evaluate
this thing.
So that if the process is
effectively stationary within
minus t0 to plus t0, I don't
need to know anything else to
evaluate all of these
linear functionals.
But that's exactly the way
that were choosing this
quantity, T0.
Namely, we're choosing T0 to
be so large that everything
we're interested in happens
inside of there.
So we're saying that all of
these linear functionals for
effective stationarity are just
defined for what happens
inside this interval.
So if Z of t is effectively
wide-sense stationary within
this interval, you make the
intervals large as you want or
as small as you want.
The real quantity is that these
functions g have to be
constrained within minus
T0 to plus T0.
Then Vi, Vj, are jointly
Gaussian.
In other words, you can talk
about jointly Gaussian without
talking at all about whether
the process is really
stationary or not.
You can evaluate this for
everything within these
limits, strictly in terms
of what's going on
within those limits.
That one was easy.
The next one is a
little harder.
We have our linear filter now.
We have the noise process going
into a linear filter.
And we have some
kind of process
coming out of the filter.
Again, we would like to say we
couldn't care less about what
this process is doing outside
of these humongous limits.
And the way we do that
is to say --
well, let's forget about that
for the time being.
Let us do what you did as an
undergraduate, before you
acquired wisdom, and say let's
just integrate and not worry
at all about changing orders of
integration or anything else.
Let's just run along and
do everything as
carelessly as we want to.
The covariance function for what
comes out of this filter
is something we already
evaluated.
Namely, what you want to look
at is v of t and v of tau. v
of t is this integral here. v
of tau is this integral here
with tau substituted for t.
So when you put both of these
together and you take the
expected value, and then you
bring the expected value in
through the integrals --
who knows whether you can do
that or not, but we'll do it
anyway -- what we're going to
get is a double integral of
the impulse response, evaluated
at t minus t1, times
the covariance function
evaluated at t1 and t2, times
the function that we're dealing
with, h, evaluated at
tau minus t2.
This is what you got just by
taking the expected value of v
of t times v of tau.
And you just write it out.
You write out the expected value
of these two integrals.
It's what we did last time.
It's what's in the notes if you
don't see how to do it.
You take the expected
value inside, and
this is what you get.
Well now we start playing
these games.
And the first game to play is,
we would like to use our
notion of stationarity.
So in place of kz of t1 and t2,
we want to substitute the
single variable form, kz
tilde of t1 minus t2.
But we don't like the t1 minus
t2 in there, so we substitute
phi for t1 and t2.
And then what we get is
the double integral
of kz of phi now.
And we have gotten rid of t1
by this substitution, so we
wind up with the integral
over phi and over t2.
Next thing we want to
do, we want to get
rid of the t2 also.
So we're going to let mu
equal t2 minus tau.
When we were starting here, we
had four variables, t and tau
and t1 and t2.
We're not getting rid of the t
and we're not getting rid of
the tau, because that's what
we're trying to calculate.
But we can play around with the
t1 and t2 as much as we
want, and we can substitute
variables of integration here.
So mu is going to
be t2 minus tau.
That's going to let us
get rid of the t2.
And we wind up with this form
here when we do that
substitution.
It's just that h of tau minus
t2 becomes h of minus mu
instead of h of plus mu.
I don't know what that means.
I don't care what it means.
The only thing I'm interested
in now is, you look at where
the t's and the taus are, and
the only place that t's and
taus occur are here.
And they occur together.
And the only thing this is a
function of is t minus tau.
I don't know what kind of
function it is, but the only
thing we're dealing with
is t minus tau.
I don't know whether these
intervals exists or not.
I can't make any very good
argument that they can.
But if they do exist, it's a
function only of t minus tau.
So aside from the
pseudo-mathematics we've been
using, V of t is wide-sense
stationary.
OK?
Now if you didn't follow
all this integration,
don't worry about it.
It's all just substituting
integrals
and integrating away.
And it's something you can do.
Some people just take five
minutes to do it, some people
10 minutes to do it.
Now we want to put the effective
stationarity in it.
Because again, we don't
know what this means.
We can't interpret what
it means in terms of
stationarity.
So we're going to assume that
our filter, h of t, has a
finite duration impulse
response.
So I'm going to assume that it's
zero when the magnitude
of t is greater than A. Again,
I'm assuming a filter which
starts before zero and runs
until after zero.
Because again, what I'm assuming
is the receiver
timing is different from
the transmitter timing.
And I've set the receiver
timing at
some convenient place.
So my filter starts doing things
before anything hits
it, just because of this
change of time.
So v of t, then, is equal to the
integral of the process Z
of t1 times h of t minus t1.
This is a linear functional
again.
This depends only on what Z of
t1 is for t minus A less than
or equal to t1, less than or
equal to t plus A. Because I'm
doing this integration here,
this function here is 0
outside of that interval.
I'm assuming that h of t is
equal to 0 outside of this
finite interval.
And this is just a shift
of t1 on it.
So this integral is going to be
equal to zero from when t
is equal to t1 minus A to when t
is equal to t1 plus A. Every
place else, this is
equal to zero.
So V of t, the whole process
depends -- and if we only want
to evaluate it within minus T0
plus A to T0 minus A -- in
other words we look at 10 to
the eighth years and we
subtract off a microsecond
from that region.
So now we're saying we want to
see whether this is wide-sense
stationary within 10 to the
eighth years minus a
microsecond, minus that
to plus that.
So that's what we're
dealing with here.
V of t in this region depends
only on Z of t for t in the
interval minus T0 to plus T0.
In other words, when you're
calculating V of t for any
time in this interval, you're
only interested in Z of t,
which is diddling within plus
or minus A of that.
Because that's the only
place where the
filter is doing anything.
So V of t depends
only on Z of t.
And here, I'm going to assume
that Z of t is wide-sense
stationary within
those limits.
And therefore I don't have to
worry about what Z of t is
doing outside of those limits.
So if the sample functions of Z
of t are L2 within minus T0
to plus T0, then the sample
functions of V of t are L2
within minus T0 plus
A to T0 minus A.
Now this is not obvious.
And there's a proof in the
notes of this, which goes
through all this L1 stuff and
L2 stuff that you've been
struggling with.
It's not a difficult proof,
but if you don't dig L2
theory, be my guest and
don't worry about it.
If you do want to really
understand exactly what's
going on here, be my guest and
do worry about it, and go
through it.
But it's not really
an awful argument.
But this is what happens.
So what this says is we can
now view wide-sense
stationarity and stationarity,
at least for Gaussian
processes, as a limit of
effectively wide-sense
stationary processes.
In other words, so long as
I deal with filters whose
impulse response is constrained
in time, the only
effect of that filtering is to
reduce the interval over which
the process is wide-sense
stationary by the quantity A.
And the quantity A is going to
be very much smaller than T0,
because we're going to choose
T0 to be as large as
we want it to be.
Namely, that's always the thing
that we do when we try
to go through limiting
arguments.
So what we're saying here
is, by using effective
stationarity, we have managed
to find a tool that lets us
look at stationary as a limit
of effectively stationary
processes as you let T0 become
larger and larger.
And we have our cake and
we eat it too, here.
Because at this point, all these
functions we're dealing
with, we can assume
that they're L2.
Because they're L2 for every
T0 that we want to look at.
So we don't have to worry
about that anymore.
So we have these processes.
Now we will just call them
stationary or wide-sense
stationary.
Because we know that what we're
really talking about is
a limit as T0 goes to infinity
of things that
make perfect sense.
So suddenly the mystery, or the
pseudo-mystery has been
taken out of this, I hope.
So you have a wide-sense
stationary process with a
covariance now of
k sub z of tau.
In other words, it's effectively
stationary over
some very large interval, and
I now have this covariance
function, which is a function
of one variable.
I want to define the spectral
density of this process as a
Fourier transform of k sub z.
In other words, as soon as I get
a one variable covariance
function, I can talk about
its Fourier transform.
At least assuming that
it's L2 or something.
And let's forget about that for
the time being, because
that all works.
We want to take the Fourier
transform of that.
I'm going to call that
spectral density.
Now if I call that spectral
density, the thing you ought
to want to know is, why am I
calling that spectral density?
What does it have to do with
anything you might be
interested in?
Well, we look at it and we say
well, what might it have to do
with anything?
Well, the first thing we're
going to try is to say, what
happens to these linear
functionals we've
been talking about?
We have a linear functional, V.
It's an integral of g of t
times Z of t dt.
We would like to be able to talk
about the expected value
of V squared.
Talk about zero-mean things,
so we don't care about the
mean at zero.
So we'll just talk about the
variance of any linear
functional of this form.
If I can talk about the
variance of any linear
functional for any g of t that
I'm interested in, I can
certainly say a lot about what
this process is doing.
So I want to find
that variance.
If I write this out, it's
same thing we've been
writing out all along.
It's the integral of g of t
times this one variable
covariance function now, times
g of tau d tau dt.
When you look at this, and
you say OK, what is this?
It's an integral of g of t
times some function of t.
And that function of
t is really the
convolution of k sub z.
This is a function now.
It's not a random process
anymore; it's just a function.
That's a convolution of the
function k tilde with g.
So I can rewrite this as the
integral of g of t times this
convolution of t.
And then I'm going to call the
convolution theta of t, just
to give it a name.
So this variance is equal to g
of t times this function theta
of t, which is just the
convolution of k with g.
Well now I say, OK, I
can use I can use
Parseval's relation on that.
And what I get is this integral,
if I look in the
frequency domain now, as the
integral of the Fourier
transform of g of t, times the
complex conjugate of theta
star of f times df.
I've cheated it you just a
little bit there because what
I really want to talk
about is --
I mean, Parseval's theorem
relates this quantity to this
quantity, where theta is theta
complex conjugate.
But fortunately,
theta is real.
Because g is real
and k is real.
Because we're only dealing with
real processes here, and
we're only dealing with
real filters.
So this is real, this is real.
So this integral is equal to
this in the frequency domain.
And now, what is the Fourier
transform of --
OK, theta of t is this
convolution.
When I take the Fourier
transform of theta, what I get
is the product of the Fourier
transform of k times the
Fourier transform of g.
So in fact what I get is g hat
of f times theta star of f.
Which is g complex conjugate
of that times k complex
conjugate -- times -- it doesn't
make any difference
whether it's a complex
conjugate or not,
because it's real.
So I wind up with the integral
of the magnitude squared of g
times this spectral density.
Well at this point, we can
interpret all sorts
of things from this.
And we now know that we can
interpret this also in terms
of effectively stationary
things.
So we don't have any problem
with things going to infinity
or anything.
I mean, you can go through this
argument carefully for
effectively stationary things,
and everything works out fine.
So long as g of t is constrained
in time.
Well now, I can choose
this function any
way that I want to.
In other words, I can choose
my function g of t in
any way I want to.
I can choose this function
in any way I want to.
So long as its inverse
transform is real.
Which means g hat of f has to
be equal to g hat of minus f
complex conjugate.
But aside from that, I can
choose this to be anything.
And if I choose this to be very,
very narrow band, what
is this doing?
It's saying that if I take a
very narrow band g of t, like
a sinusoid truncated out to
some very wide region, I
multiply that by this process, I
integrate it out, and I look
at the variance.
What am I doing when
I'm doing that?
I'm effectively filtering my
process with a very, very
narrow band filter, and I'm
asking, what's the variance of
the output?
So the variance of the output
really is related to the
amount of energy in this process
at that frequency.
That's exactly what the
mathematics says here.
It says that s sub z of f is
in fact the amount of noise
power per unit bandwidth
at this frequency.
It's the only way you
can interpret it.
Because I can make this as
narrow as I want to, so that
if there is any interpretation
of something in this process
as being at one frequency rather
than another frequency
and the only way I can interpret
that is by filtering
the process.
This is saying that when you
filter the process, what you
see at that bandwidth is how
much power there is in the
process at that bandwidth.
So this is simply giving us an
interpretation of spectral
density as power per
unit bandwidth.
OK, let's go on with this.
If this spectral density is
constant over all frequencies
of interest, we say
that it's white.
Here's the answer to your
question: what is white
Gaussian noise?
White Gaussian noise is a
Gaussian process which has a
constant spectral density over
the frequencies that we're
interested in.
So we now have this looking
at it in a certain band of
frequencies.
You know, if you think about
this in more or less practical
terms, suppose you're building
a wireless network, and it's
going to operate, say, at
five or six gigahertz.
And suppose your bandwidth
is maybe 100
megahertz or something.
Or maybe it's 10 megahertz,
or maybe it's 1 megahertz.
In terms of this frequency of
many gigahertz, you're talking
about very narrowband
communication.
People might call it wideband
communication, but it's really
pretty narrowband.
Now suppose you have Gaussian
noise, which is caused by all
of these small tiny noise
affects all over the place.
And you ask, is this going
to be flat or is it
not going to be flat?
Well, you might look at it and
say, well, if there's no noise
in this little band and there's
a lot of noise in this
band, I'm going to use this
little band here.
But after you get all done
playing those games, what
you're saying is, well,
this noise is sort of
uniform over this band.
And therefore if I'm only
transmitting in that band, if
I never transmit anything
outside of that band, there's
no way you can tell what the
noise is outside of that band.
You all know that the noise
you experience if you're
dealing with a carrier frequency
in the kilohertz
band is very different than what
you see in the megahertz
band, is very different from
what you see at 100 megahertz,
is very different from what you
see in the gigahertz band,
see in the optical bands.
And all of that stuff.
So it doesn't make any sense
to model the noise as being
uniform spectral density over
all of that region.
So the only thing we would ever
want to do is to model
the noise as having a uniform
density over this narrowband
that we're interested in.
And that's how we define
white Gaussian noise.
We say the noise is white
Gaussian noise if, in fact,
when we go out and measure it
we can measure it by passing
it through a filter by finding
this variance, which is
exactly what we're talking about
here, if what we get at
one frequency is the
same as what we
get at another frequency.
So long as we're talking about
the frequencies of interest,
then we say it's white.
Now how long do we have to
make this measurement?
Well, we don't make it forever,
because all the
filters we're using and
everything else are filters
which only have a duration over
a certain amount of time.
We only use our device over
So what we're interested in is
looking at the noise over some
large effective time from
minus T0 to plus T0.
We want the noise to be
effectively stationary within
minus T0 to plus T0.
And then what's the next
step in the argument?
You want the noise to be
effectively stationary between
these very broad limits.
And then we think about
it for a little bit,
and we say, but listen.
I'm only using this thing in a
very small fraction of that
time region.
And therefore as far as my
model is concerned, I
shouldn't be bothered
with T0 at all.
I should just say
mathematically, this process
is going to be stationary, and
I forget about the T0.
And I look at it in frequency,
and I say I'm going to use
this over my 10 megahertz or
100 megahertz, or whatever
frequency band I'm
interested in.
And I'm only interested
in what the
noise is in that band.
I don't want to specify
what the bandwidth is.
And therefore I say, I will just
model it as being uniform
over all frequencies.
So what white noise is, is
you have effectively
gotten rid of the T0.
You've effectively gotten
rid of the w0.
And after you've gotten rid of
both of these things, you have
noise which has constant
spectral density over all
frequencies, and noise way
which has constant
power over all time.
And you look at it,
and what happens?
If you take the inverse Fourier
transform of sz of f,
and you assume that sz of f is
just non-zero within a certain
frequency band, what you get
when you take the Fourier
transform is a little kind
of wiggle around zero.
And that's all very
interesting.
If you then say well, I
don't care about that.
I just like to assume that
it's uniform over all
frequencies.
You then take the Fourier
transform, and what you've got
is an impulse function.
And what the impulse function
tells you is, when you pass
the noise through a filter, what
comes out of the filter,
just like any time you deal
with impulse functions --
I mean, the impulse response
is in fact the
response to an impulse.
So that as far as the output
from the filter goes,
it's all very fine.
It only cares about what the
integral is of that pulse.
And the integral of the pulse
doesn't depend very much on
what happens at enormously large
frequencies or anything.
So all of that's well behaved,
so long as you go through some
kind of filtering first.
Unfortunately, as soon as you
start talking about a
covariance function which
is an impulse,
you're in real trouble.
Because the covariance function
evaluated at zero is
the power in the process.
And the power in the process
is then infinite.
So you wind up with this process
which is easy to work
with any time you filter it.
It's easy to work with because
you don't have these constants
capital T0 and capital
W0 stuck in them.
Which you don't really care
about, because what you're
assuming is you can wander
around as much as you want in
frequency, subject to
the antennas and
so on that you have.
And you want to be able to
wander around as much in time
as you want to and assume that
things are uniform over all
that region.
But you then have this problem
that you have a noise process
which just doesn't make
any sense at all.
Because it's infinite
everywhere.
You look at any little frequency
band of it and it
has infinite energy if you
integrate over all time.
So you really want to somehow
use these ideas of being
effectively stationary and of
being effectively bandlimited,
and say what I want
is noise which is
flat over those regions.
Now what we're going to do after
the quiz, which is on
Wednesday, is we're going to
start talking about how you
actually detect signals in
the presence of noise.
And what we're going to find
out is, when the noise is
white in the sense -- namely,
when it behaves the same over
all the degrees of freedom that
we're looking at -- then
it doesn't matter where
you put your signal.
You can put your signal anywhere
in this huge time
space, in this huge bandwidth
that we're talking about.
And we somehow want
to find out how to
detect signals there.
And we find out that the
detection process is
independent of what time we're
looking at and what frequency
we're looking at.
So what we have to focus on is
this relatively small interval
of time and relatively small
interval of bandwidth.
So all of this works well.
Which is why we assume
white Gaussian noise.
But the white Gaussian noise
assumption really makes sense
when you're looking at what the
noise looks like in these
various degrees of freedom.
Namely, what the noise looks
like when you pass the noise
through a filter and look at
the output at specific
instance of time.
And that's where the modeling
assumption is come in.
So this is really a very
sophisticated use of modeling.
Did the engineers who created
this sense of modeling have
any idea of what they
were doing?
No.
They didn't have the foggiest
idea of what they were doing,
except they had common sense.
And they had enough common
sense to realize that no
matter where they put their
signals, this same noise was
going to be affecting them.
And because of that, what they
did is they created some kind
of pseudo-theory, which said we
have noise which looks the
same wherever it is.
Mathematicians got a hold of
it, went through all this
theory of generalized
functions,
came back to the engineers.
The engineers couldn't
understand any of that, and
it's been going back
and forth forever.
Where we are now, I think, is we
have a theory where we can
actually look at finite time
intervals, finite frequency
intervals, see what's going on
there, make mathematical sense
out of it, and then say that
the results don't depend on
what t0 is or w0 is, so
we can leave it out.
And at that point we really
have our cake and
we can eat it too.
So we can do what the engineers
I've always been
doing, but we really understand
it at this point.
OK.
I think I will stop
at that point.